hi my name's Samuel Leeds and in this
video I'm gonna be explaining why you
need to know what article 4 is what it
is how you can avoid it and as an
investor how that you could potentially
ruin your HMO business unless you're
aware of it article 4 is something that
I used to say it doesn't really affect
that many areas it's a zone a nasty
thing that councils put into cities or
towns which means that if you're gonna
buy a property and convert it into an
HMO you'll need planning permission and
planning permission is a pain to put in
place so I used to say a few years ago
that you could just go point to
somewhere on the map of England and it's
probably not going to be article 4
however that is changing because the
council's are bringing article 4 in more
and more and more they've just brought
it in to Wolverhampton which is an area
where I used to buy loads of HMOs and
now icons so what do we do about this
well you've got two options option
number one is you can just get planning
permission I could just stubbornly say
I'm going to continue buying houses in
water Hampton and converting them into
HMOs and I'll just go through the
planning permission process however I'd
be stupid to do that because next door
to water Hampton is Warsaw where you
don't need planning permission and the
houses are just the same price HMOs work
pretty much everywhere as long as it's
in the city people will want rooms so I
think the smart thing to do is to just
keep going to the areas that haven't got
article 4 but what will happen is the
council are going to keep putting
article 4 in more and more cities why do
they do this I don't know exactly what
they put article 4 into cities but what
I do believe in is what Jim Rohn says
Jim Rohn says this it's not about the
blowing of the wind that determines your
destination it's not about what the
economy does what the government does
with that determines your destination as
a property investor it's not the blowing
of the wind because the same wind blows
on us all it's the setting of the sail
that determines your destination
so I actually love article 4 because all
I bought a load of houses in water
Hamilton just before article 4 came in
now the fact that I've got lots of
houses in Wolverhampton and now it's an
article
for area which means that no one can buy
HMO in Wolverhampton anymore or buy a
house and turn it into HMO
what's that done to the value of my HMOs
well number one is the value is gone and
shut up I know it has because people
have offered to buy my HMOs off me for
considerably more than I bought them six
twelve months ago and number two is it's
got rid of all my competition all the
people that would like to buy in the
area rents out rooms because they can't
so its meaning that my rents have gone
up as well so I guess the lesson in this
is to find areas that have a demand for
rooms like Grimsby Bradford Oh
Middlesbrough there's lots and lots of
areas that haven't got before that are
bringing article four in soon HMOs are
incredible it's a great product with a
massive demand but they're gonna make it
harder to people down the line but
here's the good news if you buy a house
right now and it's not in an article for
area and then they've changed the rules
and bring in article 4 it won't affect
you because you will have the
grandfather right I love grandfather
rights which means it only affects
people that buy after the article four
has come in so the lesson here is
foreign properties that don't have
article four by in those areas wait for
the article four to come in watch your
rents and your house values shoot up in
value and you'll be so glad you did how
do you find out if an area is article
four or not one asks an investor just
say hey is this Erick illogical for in
it I shouldn't have said that I don't
wanna be bombarded because to ring the
council just ring them up and say hey as
your city got article four in it they'll
tell you all three type write down this
website and this will tell you
everything you need to know www dot G o
o GL e dot current UK Google just google
it put the city followed by article four
and it should tell you whether it's got
article four in it and if you can't find
anything then it's probably because it
doesn't so that's the video that article
for I hope that's been helpful please do
feel free to put your comments below and
I'll do my best to answer very soon I'm
going to be bringing out another
which is HMO rules and regulations
mortgage hmmm rules and regulations
licensing and council tax because it is
important you know the rules
but just remember don't be put off by
some of the red tape this is easy and I
just bought a house last week HM oh I
paid no stamp duty and it was a no money
down bill
and I'm gonna be explaining how I did
that as well very soon so please if you
run no more subscribe right now below
and I'll see you soon
god bless